one night we were brainstorming a dating
app and you're telling me of the lamest
story about how you lost your virginity
in the back of your mom's Dodge Ram van
but you told your college sweetheart
that he was your first you lying [ __ ] Oh
what is it [ __ ] you should just say it's
a person across there were over there
google it hey guys I am Marcy Martin
star and executive producer and I'm Tina
Gordon writer and director of little and
this is our scene brightness down so
we're about to watch the scene where
Lisa which is aka April finds out that
Jordan is little Jordan now and they
have their first exchange with her
bosses
yeah our bus is her bus no you're not
are you related to Jordan so you see her
too
this is like the first scene that they
see us together see who the little girl
where's Jordan Jordan at that point do
you really want to know Jordan has just
become a little yeah Peter that would
happen cooker your little easy-bake of
it if it does a great job of being so
creeped out where are you I got your dry
cleaning and I love your body
baby I remember sweeping your legs up
both groan in your penthouse I wanted to
have as much of her adult postures as
possible I mean I knew that post two I
just [ __ ] why I'm on the phone
a jury aiding in my wonderful couch and
we keep Regina present in the movie with
the art so that when Marseille shows up
you always remember who she was big I
got big and I got rich I wish you were
little rich person you probably think
that they got a bunch of clothes they
got probably paintings around the house
it probably a diva you know to have a
penthouse high above everyone else
removed from people she surrounded
herself with all of that armor big dog
big dog get back to work whose child is
this walking around here in a tiny pink
pantsuit oh yeah boss let's go be a
walking cane exactly reinforce that
someone moved into that apartment
already let me be gonna keep that ya ass
to keep it
she would never give her pond to a child
death that right a little-known fact
Marseille Martin and Regina Hall are the
same side they showed up on set and the
road looks like it fits you yeah and
Tina was like oh it was right but I
don't think it looks right so you
actually have to do a lot of alterations
on the road and just like the whole
outfit in general we just had to make it
like a bigger size like it was juicy if
you know what sucks that that she wasn't
same sizes even when Regina like wasn't
working that day she would still be
there we said Regina you don't have to
come right I know that's a lot of improv
and especially with Regina
like your legs and Tina there's like it
was I don't know what you did or how you
did something according crazy little
Chucky doll I'll go to the cops
um you had a strawberry donut stain on
your shirt yesterday Luca who one night
we were brainstorming a dating app and
you're telling me of the lamest story
about how you lost your virginity in the
back of your mom's Dodge Ram van but you
told your college sweetheart that he was
your first everybody had their there
improving days or their improving scenes
people all came ready to play okay so
you know in the trailer when I say
looking like cookie from Empire that was
a head live I didn't realize it was
gonna come to the trailer you know I was
gonna they like my stuff you're like
what I had to say did you like being
able to say such harsh language to
adults like that was easy I mean I was
comfortable you know
just lying thoughts I mean I'm good I
don't know well okay thanks so much for
watching our seen breakdown pitch little
and theatres April phone and get your
tickets on Fandango
[Music]
[Music]